BORDER IF THEY'RE HEADED FOR
TEXAS.
>> Charles: THANKS.
THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE
OFFICIALS HERE GOING TO BRACE
FOR THIS LATEST SURGE.
I WANT TO BRING IN DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY,
CHRIS OLIVERAS THAT JOINS US
NOW.
WHAT IS THE PLAN?
OBVIOUSLY SO WELL-ORGANIZED AND
SO BRAZEN AND SO CONFIDENT,
HOW -- WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY GO
TO THE BOREDER?
>> GREAT TOO BE WITH YOU,
CHARLES.
WE'RE CLOSELY MONITORING THIS
CARAVAN RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN JUST -- WE CAN MOBILIZE
RESOURCES AT A MOMENT'S NOTICE.
WE HAVE A GREAT PARTNER WITH THE
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD THAT HAS
DEPLOYED THOUSANDS.
BUT WHAT TOOK PLACE IN DEL RIO
WITH THE HAITIANS, TEXAS WILL
NOT ALLOW THAT.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE'RE CLOSELY MONITORING THIS
CARAVAN.
WE'LL WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THE QUESTION IS, ONCE THEY GET
TO A CERTAIN LOCATION, WHERE ARE
THEY GOING TO BREAK OFF AND
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO END UP.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PLENTY OF
ASSETS IN PLACE TO DETER THIS
CARAVAN FROM SURGING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT WAS THE MESSAGE?
YOU HAVE FOLKS FROM ALL OVER THE
PLANET REALLY.
IT'S LIKE A UNITED NATIONS.
THERE'S A QR CODE, A LOT OF
MONEY HAD TO GO INTO THE
ORGANIZATION OF THIS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE MESSAGE
WAS?
GET TO THE BORDER AND YOU
MENTIONED YOUR FEDERAL PARTNERS.
ONCE YOU GET PAST THE BORDER
PATROL, SOME FEDERAL AGENCY WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR YOU TO GET
INTO THE UNITED STATES?
>> THAT'S THE ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
THE ISSUE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SENT OUT THIS MESSAGE THAT RIGHT
NOW IS THE TIME TO COME TO THE
U.S.
YOU'LL BE LET IN TO THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE LARGE
GROUPS OF CARAVANS SURGING THE
BORDER.
WE SAW THAT IN DEL RIO AND
CONTINUING TO SEE THAT DAY IN
AND DAY OUT.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER EVERY DAY.
SO THE PROBLEM IS THE MESSAMESS.
COME TO THE U.S. AND YOU'LL BE
LET FREE.
THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCES.
THERE'S NO RULE OF LAW THAT IS
BEING ENFORCED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHY TEXAS IS STEPPING IN,
WE'RE STEPPING IN.
WE'RE GOING TO DO WHAT WE CAN AS
FAR AS THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTAIN THIS SURGE.
NOT ONLY THAT, CHARLES, WE ARE
ARRESTING ILLEGALS COMING
ACROSS.
SO WE'RE MAKING ARREST.
WE MADE OVER 1,400 ARRESTS SINCE
JULY.
THE MESSAGE WE'RE SENDING, DON'T
COME TO TEXAS.
IF YOU DO, YOU'LL BE ARRESTED
AND YOU'LL BE PLACED BEHIND
BARS.
>> Charles: 1.7 MILLION
APPREHENSIONS, SHATTERING ALL
RECORDS OUT THERE.
STILL THE BIG MAJOR ORGANIZED
CARAVANS CONTINUE.
ARE YOU UPSET OR FRUSTRATED WITH
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
WAS PRESIDENT A LOT OF
RESISTANCE THERE.
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
FEDERAL, OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NEED TO WORK OUT WITH THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE TO PUT MORE PRESSURE
ON THEM TO STOPPING THE
CARAVANS.
WHAT WE SAW IN THE VIDEOS,
THAT'S NOT TAKING PLACE.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE A STAND AND
HAVE ACTION TO PREVENT THESE
CARAVANS.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S SO MUCH MONEY
INVOLVED WITH HUMAN SMUGGLING,
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN INSIGHT,
RIGHT NOW HUMAN SOMETHINMUGGLIN
MAKING OVER $100 MILLION A WEEK.
THEY HAVE SO MUCH POWER RIGHT
NOW, IT'S DIFFICULT TO SHUT
THESE GROUPS DOWN.
AS LONG AS THE MESSAGE IS BEING
SENT TO COME TO THE U.S., WE'LL
CONTINUE SEEING THE CARAVANS
MAKING THEIR WAY TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> Charles: I HAVE TO WRAP THIS
UP.
$100 MILLION A WEEK.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GETTING FROM
OUR RESOURCES, FROM OUR SOURCES
THAT THEY'RE MAKING WELL OVER
$100 A WEE